hamel justement après l'émission hier
ils étaient dans quel état il était
mieux mieux comment ça lui a fait du
bien ça lui a fait vraiment du bien ça
s'est passé c'est important pour moi et
pour nous ça lui a fait du bien parce
que on a eu vraiment un énorme coup de
coeur pour lui dans quel état il est
aujourd'hui
ça va et vab il va mieux ben ouais parce
que l'aij se sent qu'il est possible
c'est ça il est plus tout seul là il a
vu il a vu il a dû avoir énormément de
messages aussi de soutien je prends
énormément énormément beaucoup beaucoup
d'ailleurs on tenait à vous remercier on
s'attendait vraiment pas du tout à ça et
à beaucoup de personnes aussi qu'ils se
sont vus à travers via nice et ça s'est
passé personne est au contraire qu'il
vienne témoigner qu'il vienne nous dire
les choses mais on décide des idées
derrière fabrice il a fait un travail
magnifique aujourd'hui va nous en parler
et c'est vrai que c'était très important
pour nous qu'ils se sentent mieux et je
suis très heureux que vous me disiez que
cette émission ne le fait du bien qui
l'a vu tout le soutien qu'il avait il a
pris cette décision alors il va il va
venir un petit peu avec nous a dit oui
d'accord n'a pas dit à sa mère janis
sera un petit peu avec la semaine faire
beaucoup avec nous à yanis j'espère que
ça va aussi le voilà l'une de donner
envie de faire autre chose de deux
matches et si on peut l'aider ou les
draps vraiment le mieux qu'on peut et je
sais que fabrice aujourd'hui vous avez
avancé également sur le dossier alors en
fait vous soumet qu'hier soir yanis
avait dit qu'il a été victime de
plusieurs agressions
et qui avait été classé 5 sur il avait
porté porté plainte et pendant des
dizaines d'années à cinq dossiers là à
d'accord avec celui ci ça fait cinq
dossiers
celui ci en fait on est en
identification des auteurs alors qu'en
fait on a reconnu trois ou quatre
personnes qui ont été déférés présenté à
un juge et on a du mal comme dans toutes
ces affaires un peu de groupes à un
accord analyser les bandes on regarde un
petit peu qu'ils aient qui voit là les
versions divergent un petit peu comme
toujours
ensuite dans les autres agressions qu'il
a eue ce qui se passe c'est que en fait
on est tombé un petit peu dans les
méandres de la justice c'est pas des
classements sans suite en fait c'est que
le dossier suit son cours mais ce trail
son court mais très très long parce que
là aussi il ya un preuve d'implication
des auteurs par contre effectivement ce
que je peux dire c'est que
incontestablement le dossier n'est pas
du tout jeter à la poubelle si on peut
dire ça d'accord au contraire il est
suivi et qui plus est c'est important
j'ai dit à la mandia nice aujourd'hui au
téléphone que j'allais effectivement
avec l'accord des services du parquet
sollicité un rendez vous que le
procureur de la république pour que la
knicks entendent de ses propres oreilles
que la justice le respecte et qui
s'intéresse finalement à son statut de
victime et qu'il n'y a pas du tout une
volonté en fait de minimiser ce qui
s'est passé et de le mettre à l'écart
mais c'est juste que hélas la justice
avec peu de moyens avec ce qu'on connaît
finalement parfois bas de travail avec
le rythme qui est le sien mais et donc
du coup ça c'est le premier aspect donc
demandé un rendez vous procure de la
république pour que vraiment la famille
de yanis entendent que non ce qui s'est
passé n'est pas normal et que l'état est
vraiment aussi aux côtés des victimes et
et le yanis en particulier donc ça c'est
vraiment très important parce que
ces quatre plaintes comme s'assurer
qu'elle n'a pas de nouvelles ça peut
donner vraiment cette impression que
finalement abandonner totalement va pas
du tout en fait et donc n'a mon rôle à
moi ça va être précisément de faire
accélérer le processus de relance et un
peu la machine de ces douars un peu où
on est qui qui qui on est et où un petit
peu et surtout permettre je le redis à
la mondialiste et annick une lettre
reçue par l'institution judiciaire pour
que vraiment on entende qui soit kifa
victime et enfin deuxième fois on a eu
un contact aujourd'hui avec des gens qui
proposent à yanis et à la famille de
yanis en fait soit deux fois de partir
de changer de quartier de l'échangé de
ville et de lui trouver un travail enfin
même de lui offrir un travail fait
qu'ils sont à l'as comment ça se passe
entre lyon et bourg-en-bresse d'accord
ils ont ils ont en fait ce qui se passe
c'est que en logements pour le oui oui
tout à fait ils ont un logement pour la
famille en fait ils ont plusieurs
logements et il propose d'en mettre à
disposition donc de la famille de gagny
ce de façon à permettre égalise de
ressortir tranquillement de s'aérer et
au moins ils ont invité effectivement la
famille de gagny ça a passé un week end
au moins un week-end au vert si vous
voulez voir déjà on pouvait déjà soufflé
et voir ensuite se rencontrer les
acteurs locaux qui seraient prêts à
recruter yanis est vraiment à lorient t
elle prendre en main vraiment nous
permettre de changer de vie alors avec
nous sans sa famille ça c'est lui qui
choisit mais sa famille peut être
accueillis dans un logement sans aucun
problème donc sa belle bout hamel vous
avez vous avez eu cette proposition
qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit vos parents
baïse et tous les poètes papa way est
malade je les ai eus hier en face time
il est illettré souffrons qu'est ce que
c'est et quazar action ils disent quoi
vos parents ils sont prêts à
son compte en
mai par rapport à l'époque mon père il
n'ose pas trop parce que il est devenu
trappe legic à cause du colis du coup
pour eux c'est un peu compliqué tout ça
mais sont contents
je sais que c'est très compliqué pour
votre papa
donc ils ont cette proposition on va
voir comment ils vont on l'appréhendé
qualité leur action ils ont vu tout le
soutien qu'il y avait autour de yanis
hier
ils étaient vraiment
choquant fin étonné ils étaient contents
eux aussi ça les a rassurés de voir qu
avait autant de personnes derrière et à
nice pour cette affaire parce que avant
avant ça il n'avait pas énormément de
soutien par rapport aux agrumes qu'il
avait subie avant celle ci et là ils ont
vraiment vu qu' il n'était pas tout seul
et ça les a vraiment rassuré tout ça
quand vous êtes rentré hier soir
il avait une appréhension yanis ou salé
il l'avait ouais il avait il osé pas
trop au début il avait peur on va dire
ce qu'il s'est dit ça se trouve on on va
d'abord on va me frapper alors du coup
c'est moi je suis parti de déposer
jusqu'au domicile de chez mes parents et
je suis rentré ensuite un mois mais vous
avez reçu du soutien des voisins du
voisinage des gens du quartier
au début quand depuis hier encore plus
depuis hier oui justement même de la
famille oui quand ils ont vu qu'ils ont
reconnus et à nice du coup sûr et
même ça ça a vraiment touché mes parents
parce que vous êtes senti beaucoup plus
soutenu voilà c'est ça beaucoup vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup soutenu et
dans le quartier c'est que la réaction
là
ça sort des remarques pour aérer partie
s'afficher à la télé d'accord et
d'autres bail ils sont contents parce
que là où heureusement tout est venu
c'est ça et c'est vrai que comme on dit
ici on essaie de d'avoir des témoignages
très fort en émotions on essaie aussi de
vous aider apprécié ces témoignages
peuvent aider à ce que les choses
bougent on le voit avec fabrice qui a
travaillé pour pour ça aujourd'hui on ne
voit qu'il ya des solutions qui se
profile et yanis même si déjà moralement
et que votre famille moralement ils sont
plus soutenues et ils disent on va
peut-être sortir la tête de l'eau c'est
déjà pondu une énorme victoire s'est
produit aussi n'at il est vraiment même
ça se voit il est plus apaisé il est
tranquille dans sa tête et que là il va
se dire enfin est quelque chose qui va
aboutir et même par rapport à votre
proposition était vraiment je serais
content et ça lui a fait vraiment les
hervé alors aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il a
fait quoi alors il s'est reposé il est
sorti un petit peu oui il noie encore
n'a hélas pas encore réussi vraiment
reposer parce qu'avec tout ça et là
enfin elle a pu dormir et s'est reposé
oui les respecte mes parents et pour
prenez espoirs vous toujours toujours
les seuils ouais ça va aller avec le
temps comme vous avez dit hier c'est
vrai que ce drame il va peut-être faire
bouger les choses fabrice oui alors que
j'ai appris moi c'est que le quartier
gens parlent pas la même c'est que le
quartier est sujet à ce genre
d'agression que c'est assez fréquent et
là ce n'est peut-être pas dans ces
proportions mais il est vrai que s'ils
voulaient la dernière agression qui a
subi yanis a aussi fait beaucoup de
bruit bofa cette vidéo elle a beaucoup
circulé et que là je crois que c'était
important de même pour les services de
police qui connaissent a pourtant par
coeur d'avoir presque en permanence sous
les yeux la violence de l'agression en
fait est alors de manière tout à fait
à part ce qui est vrai c'est que
il ya une thèse qui tient pas si vous
voulez comme ça c'est qu'apparemment ce
qui serait en train de se dire dans ce
dossier c'est qu'il y aurait une excuse
de provocation c'est pay and i serait
provoquer
les agresseurs en tout cas en partie
mais quand on voit yanis est ce que
disait madame ne pas s'inquiéter là
dessus parce que finalement l' avantage
c'est que quand on voit la bande d'hier
soir mais quand on voit également
l'agression voit que finalement c'est sa
demande ou en fait c'est un jeune homme
d'une bosse un jeune homme doué c'est un
jaune surtout qui en a marre qui emmena
le var et qui voit là il y en a marre de
vivre avec ça normal pour ça c'est pour
ça que je reviens là dessus c'est
important que finalement que que la
famille entendre que les plaintes
contrairement à ce qui était de dire
soir qui m'étonnait quand même un peu
c'est pas qu'elles ont été classés mais
que vraiment bas la justice elle prend
du temps et mon rôle à moi il est
vraiment de faire en sorte que la saa
ski c'est parce que ce qui s'est passé
va accélérer les choses sur les autres
dossiers également à bas forcément il
peut pas on peut pas le nier forcément
parce que si vous voulez là on a affaire
on n'a plus affaire à une victime on
avait fait une victime de harcèlement
est une victime de violences à
répétition superman mais comme un moment
donné il faut la protéger c'est aussi
pour ça que moi je suis intervenu ce
matin pour débattre d'un point de presse
le procureur le moment voulu c'est à
dire maman donné peut-être qu'il faut
mettre calice aussi s'il ne change pas
de quartier sous protection mais il peut
pas rester comme ça et sont pas peur de
ressortir à ce concours mais même pour
lui ça c'est quand même une valeur
d'être sous protection c'est un bon
enfant sarah une ado de 17 ans il a
envie de sa vie comme tout le monde
comme tous les ados de 17 ans et là il
faut vraiment que ça se calme et
j'espère aussi que cette émission est le
témoignage de yanis hier a fait prendre
conscience aux agresseurs et aux gens
qui qui qui l'embêté qui l'agressé dans
le quartier qu'il faut vraiment arrêter
c'est avec mention frère il vaut mieux
essayer de l'aider essayez de s'intègre
qui kiffent un peu la vie parce que là
c'est vrai que yann ici c'est un enfer
sa vie est un enfer on va tout faire
pour qu'elle soit meilleure maintenant
oui justement quand on voit cette vidéo
on a envie que les agresseurs soient
condamnés sanctionner sévèrement qu'est
ce qu'ils risquent concrètement mettre
une visio en fonction de qualification
qui sera retenue il laisse qu'une peine
d'emprisonnement ferme
ac non quand même la véritable
difficulté c'est qu'apparemment certains
d'entre eux sont mineurs seraient
mineures en fait où l'aca tout de suite
un peu plus compliqué même si une
réforme c'est un tout petit un peu
compliqué mais si vous voulez dans ce
genre d'agressions il faut pas penser à
une justice laxiste c'est pas tout à
fait vrai quand même parce que la
violence effectivement de l'agression
les magistrats ils sont sensibles les
images circulent et là vous avez un
parquet qui va encore demander qui ont
voulu mort des réquisitions fermes avec
une peine d'emprisonnement ferme à la
clé si vous voulez c'est ce qu'avaient
dit les dossiers m est-ce qu'il s'agit à
chaque fois d'agression d'humiliation
harcèlement homophobe alors j'ai pas vu
du dossier ce que j'ai ce qu'on m'a dit
des dossiers suspects avaient fait la
même chose que dossier soit encore voilà
c'est compliqué de 7 mais de les
retrouver déjà
mais ensuite effectivement ce qui
semblerait ressortir c'est que nous
avons en tout cas d agressions à
répétition des violences volontaires
voilà à ce stade c'est ce que je sais
tellement des violences volontaires le
caractère homophobe ne semble pas
ressortir effectivement en l'état des
dossiers mais en tout cas le caractère
de violence volontaire lui avec deux
lances et cas et qui est au coeur
effectivement de l'enquète après avec un
problème c'est que dans ce dossier c'est
très compliqué d'identifier l'auteur